And this is probably good human being
advice,
not just entrepreneur and startup and
investor advice.
What I learned from Wine Library TV is
the following,
the true story of Wine Library TV was
the day that I thought I was going to
start it.
I thought I was going to do something
similar to Qvc and I don't know if you
have a qvc or shopping network in
Europe,
but QBC and America,
it's a show and they sell stuff through
the TV.
I thought I was going to do the qvc of
wine.
The first episode of that show,
when that camera went on and that light
went on,
I realized that this was going to be on
the Internet forever and that I didn't
want to just pedal wine.
I decided I wanted to be a value to
people in learning about wine because I
was scared that if I was peddling
something,
I didn't believe in that somebody would
come up to me at a party and say,
do you like this?
And they'd say,
no,
I hate it.
They're like,
well,
you fucking said it was awesome.
A one liberty.
You're a scam artist.
I'm like,
shit,
no,
so I was very focused on leveling up and
I really believe that one great piece of
advice,
if you want to take anything from this
talk,
is we have to start realizing that
giving and doing things in business
without expectation of return from the
other individual is probably the
greatest leverage that you could ever
deploy in your business life.
Though it is extremely rare in today's
business environment and it has
absolutely been the bedrock of what is
allowed me to win all my engagement,
all my selfies right over there and
signing books,
all the content I have nothing to sell.
I have a book that I fucking sell once
every three years for $13.
This is not about monetizing an
audience.
It's about building leverage to build
brand versus sales.
One of the biggest things that I see
going on right now in digital media is
that we don't have a lot of people doing
branding and marketing.
We have a lot of people doing sales.
The reason so many of you were confused
by the value of snapchat is because in
the digital landscape,
we now think transactional.
Everything's about what's the Roi of
every piece of content,
every single action,
what's the last attribution,
what's the conversion rates?
It's all become math based and that's
fine because I love sales more than
anybody,
but I promise you these fucking guys,
Nike,
they need tagged me on a browser and
then re cookie me and then travel all
over the Internet and pound me with
banner ads until I gave up and bought
it.
I bought it because they fucking market
into me over the last 20 years and I
don't even fucking know why I buy it
and that is a very important point
because what we're living through is a
time where people are just being very
transactional and conversion based when
everything continues to get arbitraged.
Another thought that I'm curious,
how many people here have gone to the
life that I've gone to over the last
three months?
I no longer have a laptop or an ipad.
I now only live through my mobile
device.
How many people are on that level doing
that?
Raise your hands.
Not a lot and this is like think about
this conference.
I really think that this trend,
I do believe that if I came back here in
two years,
that 50,
40,
30 percent of the hands in this room
would go up to that following question
and I'm completely fascinated by it and
then for everybody in the room that is
building businesses on the Internet,
the thought of what's happening in your
landing page optimization or the Ui and
Ux of your product in a desktop
environment I think is in the beginning
stages of being disrupted and that's
what I really spent most of my time in
which is what's the attention arbitrage?
Where do I think your eyes and ears are
going to be before you do and how do I
go and land grab and buy up that
property and how do I then deploy and
build the best houses on that property
through content.
That is the pattern of my career.
In 2006,
I felt this social media thing was going
to be really big and in 2007,
2008,
I've laid my foundation and by 2007 and
eight I invested in facebook and Tumbler
and twitter and things of that nature
and I did quite well.
I also use them to tell my story,
sell my wine,
do my thing.
I think this is super important to
understand because I think we also
decide that things are emerging too
fast.
This is not just being first mover.
A lot of people like to give me credit.
Like you predicted all this stuff.
You were sorry.
I just want to be on the record forever.
There's plenty of people here recording.
I've been predicted.
Shit.
I'm not.
No,
sir.
Domus.
What I've done well is I've moved
quickly once you actually started using
them.
I didn't predict twitter.
I wasn't right about snapchat.
I was just looking at data.
Snapchat two years ago when I first
started talking about it already had
tens of millions of users.
There was real people using it.
I'm not predicting anything.
I'm paying attention.
There's probably very few people in this
room there are paying as much attention
to anchor to peach,
to all these platforms as I am,
but I'm not putting all my content or
all my time and I'm also not crippled by
putting my time and effort into
platforms before they have a 100 or $200
million users.
For example,
how many of you remember that five
minutes?
Four years ago were Social Cam got big?
Raise your hand.
Alright,
so three nerds.
Social Cam got big for three minutes
because the facebook newsfeed juiced it
and it had a lot of users and it was hot
for four months,
six months.
I used it feverish Lee and use it a lot.
It collapsed and meant nothing,
but during that period I learned so much
about mobile video and the cadence of it
and how people interacted with it that
when vine came along,
a year and a half later and then
instagram video and then snapchat,
I'd already put in the work and had the
learnings from human behavior that I
deployed against the next thing.
There are way too many people in this
room that do not do actions because
crippled by the short term results
versus what it means in the long term,
and this goes to marketing and this goes
to running your business and this comes
down to what I probably want to spend a
few more minutes on right now,
which is my friends.
There's a lot of people in here that are
startup founders.
That should not be my friends,
that are a lot of people in here that
work at agencies.
That should not be.
They should be probably switched and
vice versa and different things.
One of the things that is absolutely
driving me right now in my life is the
untold depression,
the untold suicides.
To just get dark for a second,
it's not fun to talk about,
but it's important.
We are lacking self awareness in this
space in a very substantial way and
there's a lot of people that are about
to be met with a lot of disappointment
and are struggling.
How many people are an entrepreneur in
here?
Raise your hand.
You guys and gals know this isn't easy.
There's nobody else.
It's fun to work for somebody.
You know,
why you get the blame the boss,
she and he is an Asshole,
not you.
When you're an entrepreneur where
there's nobody else behind you,
it's on you,
and one thing we're not talking about is
the level of success.
Everybody thinks they have to build
fucking Uber.
Everybody thinks they have to make
millions of dollars.
It's unbelievable what we've done and I
absolutely want to make sure that we're
starting to have real conversations
making $100,000 a year,
100 year euros.
That's massively successful.
We need to recalibrate what success
looks like in our space because we're
forcing through the branding of what
we're doing.
Very impractical,
very high risk,
very low return results for so many
because everybody's shooting for 10
billion guys.
There's like four apps that big.
There's like Uber and Instagram,
like how many fucking billion dollar
companies do you think there are?
And so I really am passionate about
starting to reframe the conversation
about the number one thing that I have
noticed in my 20 years of my success.
Because let me tell you something,
I sucked shit at almost everything.
What I've done well is I've deployed
self awareness around what I am and I
know what I am and there's a lot of
things I wish I was seven years ago as a
lot of,
you know,
I had plenty of leverage in the web.
Two point.
Oh,
social media movement.
I was one of the guys.
I was one of the 20 most follow people
on twitter.
I didn't go and raise $40,000,000 to
build the next facebook.
I didn't raise $50 million dollars to
build a platform around wine.
I was self aware enough even though I
had all the opportunity in the world to
build product that I wasn't going to be
successful seven years ago I went out
and built a boring digital agency.
Right?
I built something practical.
All My internet friends,
all a lot of the people can be on the
stage.
They made fun of me.
Like,
why don't you go build a big company or
something grand.
I built what I knew I could build.
I'm very proud that over the last four
years I've grown vaynermedia from three
to $100,
million dollars a year in revenue,
not fucking valuation
and cool.
Great.
That's fine.
And who gives a shit?
What I'm way more worried about than
what I've done is what you're going to
do.
I implore you,
my friends.
This is fancy.
First of all,
this is unbelievable.
This is one of the nicest setup still
conference I've ever seen.
She.
Let's clap it up for these guys.
It's unbelievable,
right?
Fucking
food trucks.
It's like sunny and shit.
This is fucking awesome.
Anyway,
what I did well was I just didn't give a
shit when I'm.
When I'm old,
I'm 40.
When I grew up in,
in the United States,
like being a good student was the big
thing.
I was making $3,000 a weekend selling
baseball cards and getting D's and f's
and everybody thought I was a loser.
That's what the narrative was.
Now it's reversed.
If I was in school now making three,
$4,000 a weekend as a 13 year old,
I would have been the next big thing,
right?
I went through it and I did not succumb
to the current thing that everybody
thought in America was the right thing,
which was go to the best school you
could go to.
I understood who I was and I went in all
in on my strengths and I employ a lot of
you to do that.
There's too many people sitting in this
room that want to be the number one CEO
founder,
but if you were the seventh employee of
a company,
you know,
I'd much rather be number 41 at
facebook,
the number one of facebook,
and so I think we're seeing that and so
I'd like to stand up here and I'd like
to say,
look,
there's a lot of things that I wish I
was different at as matter of fact,
back to let's be very matter right now.
Do you know that I wish I didn't curse
on stage?
Do you have any people?
Don't share my content.
Don't like me because of it.
I wish I didn't do it.
I just can't be anything that I'm not
and so I implore you,
don't worry about what school right now
or what we're all focused on or what
your momma wants you to be.
You need to go home from this
conference.
You'll be inspired.
You'll be cool people.
There's interesting shit,
but I'm telling you with the bottom of
my heart,
it is fundamentally irrelevant if you
don't know who the fuck you are and the
quicker you can start forcing yourself
to understanding what role you play.
Number one.
Number seven,
PR,
marketing product you are.
Everybody wants to be somebody else.
I wish I was the quarterback of the New
York jets.
It's not gonna happen
and so if I could accomplish one,
and by the way,
I'm being very realistic.
I'll be very,
very transparent with you.
This little seven minute rant that I
just came up with.
I'm trying to reach one person like I'm.
This is not so easy.
It's hard to have the ego and the
humility at equal ends to figure
yourself out,
but I promise you,
as I've looked across the landscape,
and I've looked at 25,
50,000 startups at this point,
right?
I have now spent the last 40 years of my
life with the Toyotas and the pepsis and
the gi biggest brands enrolled myself,
my inner circle,
the one connection point from corporate
America to startup to vc to
personalities.
The one connection point is self
awareness.
Once you start understanding yourself,
once you start actually executing on who
you actually are versus who you wish you
were,
things start to change very quickly,
and so the reason I'm passionate about
this as this is always very worldly
advice and is probably historically
always good things to talk about.
I just feel that if any of you really
paid attention to the macro economic
infrastructure of what's happening in
our space right now,
this nirvana that we've lived through
for the last six or seven years is about
to shift.
It just is.
It's just the data.
I don't want it.
I wish it was nirvana forever,
just like everybody else during the down
cycles,
the people that are able to win are the
ones that are most in tune with
themselves,
the ones that are the most practical.
So again,
to make this valuable to you in this
room,
number one,
if you're a startup,
please start understanding how you're
going to make money as soon as possible.
You're running a business,
you're running a business.
Businesses need to make money,
especially when there's no money to fund
you based on your last valuation.
Number two,
as a human being sitting at this
conference,
this is all very encompassing and very
exciting,
but start chipping away against what you
think you want and start really looking
at what you bring to the table because
the quicker you figure that out,
the more successful you will have.
An number three,
please start understanding how to
provide value without expectation in
return.
It is unbelievable to me how many people
already tonight we've super five
minutes,
seven,
eight people giving me something as they
think,
but really expecting something in return
for that give.
Humans can feel that it's not the way to
go and we really need to start thinking
about that.
And number four,
understand the following,
and this is very ironic given my
concerns about where the market's going.
I'll end with this in lieu of all of
that.
This whole thing that we're living
through has just started.
The consumer web is only 20 years old.
Windows 95 kind of started this thing.
The Internet thing is very new.
Everything that we all talk about didn't
exist 10 years ago over the next 10
years,
the biggest companies in the world from
Europe and Asia and us from anywhere in
the world because we are now at scale.
The biggest companies in the world are
going to be created over the next 20
years from zero.
There are people sitting in this room
right now that are going to build the
next major company and so we are all so
blessed that we are actually human
beings during this period where there is
so much upside,
so much opportunity and so everything
I've talked about when you parallel on
the ub noxious opportunity and land grab
an opportunity.
If you're able to wire those two things
together,
I think a lot of good stuff could happen
for you,
and I'd like that for you.
I'd like that a lot.
Thank you.